[Music]
i was thinking i've been playing the
elephant all the time
let's play it's close cousin let's play
the mora because i'm planning to make
videos on the mora
and
the disclaimer i don't know quite as
much about it as about the alapan so
we'll kind of play it by ear
and i can't guarantee that i'll make the
right moves okay and this is the
starting position of the mora accepted
a6
that is
kind of a weird move i mean generally
most people start with d6 or e6 a6 is
probably not that bad but it's one of
those improvisational moves that we
should meet just by playing the normal
setup in the mora as far as i know the
bishop on f1 belongs on what square 99
of the time and i'll explain the
rationale behind that as far as i know
so yeah bishop c4 so it's worth starting
with bishop c4 you can also start with
knight f3 in such positions but but
let's start with bishop c4 and try to
force black's hand
g6
okay we need to continue our development
this whole gambit thing is not going to
work out if you lose your patience early
on and a move like queen d5 is not going
to cut it i i'm sure that some of you
are thinking about it but queen d5 black
simply plays e6 and we lose the tempo so
instead of doing anything drastic we
need to first accumulate our pieces
bishop g7 same thing here folks um
knight g5 tempting but that's not what
the mora is about knight g5 e6
and uh unfortunately if you look at that
position we would have loved to go
knight b5 knight d6 but there's already
a pawn on a6 that's guarding that square
the mora is actually an opening which
allows you to practice your fundamentals
in addition to your tactical skills
which makes it very exciting for coaches
yeah let's just castle right and i'm not
sure that this is the best way to play
this but
it's certainly not not going to be bad
e6 now those of you who have been
watching my speed run for
a while know that
i am particularly passionate about
warning people against playing e6 and g6
uh in the sicilian
why is that well it's mainly because it
it creates a massive hole on d6
and what's even worse than that is you
fianchettoed your bishop so now you have
absolutely no supervision over that
square now the best
piece to put on that square is what what
is the best square to put on dc if you
could take any of your pieces or queen
knight bishop
king
not the king which piece would you put
on d6
definitely the knight and if a knight
appeared on d6 right now right
all of you guys should see how dangerous
that is knight d6 check forces the king
to f8 then the other knight goes to g5
and you might think about this and say
well there is no way of getting the
knight to d6 efficiently
but in fact there is remember that you
can push pawns out of the way a lot of
you
make this mistake where when you're
looking for a maneuver you forget that
you can clear the pathway with your own
pieces and pawns so
one possibility here
which we're going to play right now is
to go e5
9496 f6
now
another important thing about playing
the mora is that it as far as i know it
helps you re-conceptualize your
relationship to material
a lot of you would see this move and
perhaps you're thinking well black is
threatening to take our pawn on e5 and
presumably that's an important pawn
but we have something that's even more
important than preserving the e5 pawn we
didn't play e5
in order to keep that pawn we played e5
in order to position our knight on d6 so
what should white do here
pretty much automatically knight e4 he
can take this pawn all he wants
but once we put our knight on d6 there
is going to be hell to pay that is going
to be a night that's worth its weight
and gold
understood so
we've already sacrificed one pawn and
now we sacrifice a second one
but
without even calculating a single
variation you should be intuitively
aware
that our compensation after knight e6 is
going to be completely overwhelming i
think we're just going to be winning the
game now this is this is a disaster for
black because whatever black does
here comes our knight
now we have to follow up
we have to follow up accurately
right yeah we put a knight on d6
congratulations to us
but it's not enough to just do that and
then gloat
we have to figure out how the other
pieces can combine in order to optimize
our attack now there is a very very
pretty idea here which
i think probably not a lot of you are
thinking about at the moment
now bishop g5 is of course very very
tempting but should g5 check and that's
a great move bishop g5 is probably the
second best move or maybe even the top
move
but bishop g5 black plays bishop f6 we
don't win the queen
i love that some of you are pointing
this move out where else can this bishop
be
in order to attack the king well you
might think about this and say well what
if it's on this diagonal right if it sat
on that diagonal we would have massive
threats of a discovered check
well we can get our bishop there you can
play bishop e3 bishop c5
which is great
or you can play b3 bishop a3
and
i'm gonna play in kind of a fancy way
here
let me actually think about which of
those i prefer
yeah let's go b3
and i'll explain why after the game
isn't that too slow well it's only two
moves
i i really don't think it's too slow see
we already played it and we're already
completely winning
because the only way to avoid
discoveries is to go king f6 and that is
i haven't even calculated that and i can
assure you that we're gonna find
something there
one way or another we're gonna get to
that king
so remember the three move rule i like
that as kind of a general guideline
for evaluating whether ideas are too
slow or not if a move takes three moves
or more
it's often going to be too slow this
idea only takes two moves
it's really really fast black can play
e4 we don't care about that what are we
actually threatening here what is the
biggest threat for white who can tell me
if it were white to move in this
position
and there's basically two big threats in
in
ascending order knight takes c8 was one
of them winning a piece but the biggest
one was knight takes b7 winning the
queen okay king f6 has been played
now i see a very cool sequence
that essentially enables us to force the
king
back on to e7 it it involves reshuffling
the knights in a certain way
such that
eventually the king is forced to move
back to
that diagonal
we start with 94.
you might look at this and say well
that seems counterproductive we're
retreating the knight away from what
seems like the square it has to be
sitting on but this is temporary this is
temporary and in in two moves the
knight's going to come back to d6
and what are we trying to do we're
trying to drive the king to e8
why does that help well that helps
because once we give a knight check on
d6 then the king will have a choice
between f8 and e7 both of those moves
lie on this diagonal and therefore lose
the queen so knight g5 which knight well
we need to use this knight to go to d6
so obviously we give a check with this
knight
pretty logical attacking stuff right as
long as you're aware of these retreating
night moves and you're not
uh you don't have a blind spot when it
comes to that you should be able to spot
this
and our first more outing is a
successful one
yeah look at look at how many pieces are
involved like basically all of our
miners
possibly with the exception of the light
squared bishop but even the light square
bishop did its part
okay well that is not going to solve
flax problems
thank you
all right but let's not uh let's not
rest on our laurels
let's not rest on our laurels black
wants to play d5
and if black plays d5 the game goes on
so
can we prevent
can we prevent black from going uh d5
well there we can and there's a couple
of ways to accomplish that
um
i don't love queen d6 as much as i like
bishop d6
even though if we play queen d6 we will
probably end up winning the game faster
there is a specific reason i don't love
queen d6 as much
yeah we can also play queen f3 and we
can try to go this way
but queen f3 knight f6 right it's gonna
take us some time to infiltrate anyway
so we can also go knight e4 by the way
okay if you want to play like tall
if you want to play like tall would play
you would go 94.
now it looks like you're just walking
into a fork what the hell well think
about what we're gonna do if he goes d5
because i think that's what's gonna
happen
all right well the idea is you just
blast through up a queen
when you're up a queen you can afford to
do stuff that otherwise you would
accompany with a lot more thought
we just need to blast the position open
right we need to open up the position
and get our queen
onto
a prime attacking spot what does that
mean what does it mean to open up the
position here
well yeah bishop takes d5 now we can
start with knight d6 check absolutely
nothing wrong with starting with knight
e6 but let's preserve maximum
flexibility and take on d5 first
because we never know maybe the knight
we'll go to f6 in some of these lines
really it doesn't matter you can start
with knight d6
you can play it
after e takes d5 we can throw in knight
d6 check and then take on d5
in fact the more i look at that the more
i like the idea of going knight dc yeah
let's go knight d6 strip first
because
queen takes d5 perhaps black had the
move bishop f8 which prolongs the game
so let's let's get this knight in into
the game first
now queen takes d5
is the volume low yeah let me know if
the volume is low because this is gonna
go on youtube and i know i've been
getting some complaints about the volume
okay the volume is fine knight f6
important don't blunder don't move your
knight remember that when you have an
x-ray
uh and your opponent is attacking the
piece that is delivering the actual
check unless you give a double check you
need to move that piece and there is no
double check to give with the knight
obviously the move is queen f7
and in addition to everything else we're
just winning all of black's miners
this is completely resignable and
probably tall would go rook a to d1 here
or even rook f to d1 and just go
directly for checkmate we don't even
have to take this bishop
let's go we're keft one let's go
directly for checkmate
anything is fine if you want you can
take the bishop and then take the knight
it's there's nothing to talk about here
this is elementary my dear watson
by the way the reason i played rook fd1
and not rook 81 is because the other
rook might go out to c1
resigning wins yes there we go ebola
thank you
good stuff
and that's how powerful the maura is at
this level
so
here's what i'll say i will make at some
point a video or several videos on the
mora
so i won't delve too deeply into the
opening here
you mean you guys can do your own
research for the time being all i'll say
is that i highly recommend the mora
so the reason the jalapen and the mora
are related
if black declines the gambit the best
way to decline the more is to play
knight f6
there are several ways to decline the
mora that are quite reputable one of
them is just to push this pawn forward
to d3
but here white is better after c4 white
gets the sort of morozy bind set up
but the most reputable way is to go
knight f6 and after e5 this is a direct
transposition into the alpha knight t5
now either c takes d4 or knight f3 which
we play
and if you think about it c3 knight f6
e5 knight t5 d4 al open main line
whoops nope mouse up you have the same
position
uh and most grand masters
in in fact i play the sicilian with
black i've never accepted the mario
gambit
i always play knight f6
and i think you know if you're a
sicilian player with black knight f6 is
the most practical move
you know it's the easiest to learn
you're not in danger of getting
checkmated
and you transpose into the elephant
which is still a very good opening for
white
but if you've learned the alpine from me
through the speedrun and you want to
play the mora it's a win-win for you
it's a win-win if black declines the
gambit you get to play an alapin if
black accepts it you get to checkmate
them in the mora
okay does that make sense
now the accepted mora from a purely
objective perspective is is fine for
black black is fine
in fact black has several ways
to be fine and mark astronomers will be
the first to admit that the point of
this is not to win the game objectively
right if you want to test your opponent
in objective waters play the open
sicilian go into mainline nadorf
the misconception about the people that
people have about the smith mora is that
it's bad is that if black knows what to
do this myth is bad it is not
i analyzed it not as deeply as i will
before the video but i looked at it
and
i think even if black plays perfectly
the evaluation is approximate equality
black is not better to my knowledge
whoa troublelifter for the five
black is not better to my knowledge even
with best play
all right so don't feel like you're
playing some gimmicky gambit this is a
very reputable system important
and most people in the 15 1600 range
just don't know the theory and this is
an unfamiliar position they try to play
the same way they would play in the open
sicilian and it doesn't work
and it doesn't work
and one prime example of that
is that if black plays uh like the night
or if black plays d6
bishop c4 and knight f6
who can tell me
a very well-known smith mora trap
that already poses massive problems for
black in this position
e5
e5 and if d takes e5 i'm sure you guys
are aware of this idea winning the queen
another idea
is a little bit more advanced but in
mark's game against vanueli that's one
of the most famous smithmore games
luke van whaley played the system with
e6
and you still put the bishop on c4 even
though it bites on granite because you
have a night sacrifice on d5 in some of
those positions
i mean mark's game against van gaal is
absolutely beautiful let me show that
game real fast just as a
a little um
how should i put it
little appetizer okay
i was there for that game by the way i
was watching with my own eyes i was at
that tournament playing it
so it was just a shock so venuely plays
knight c6
knight f3
e6
and now a very
counterintuitive move folks bishop c4
you i'm i'm sure you're looking at this
move thinking
this goes against everything i've been
recommending right you're just kind of
biting onto this pawn
but that's why the mora is cool because
tactics in this opening outweigh
positional considerations watch what
happens a6
covering the b5 square castles
knight ge7
the point of this move venuely avoids
knight f6 because of e5 which is very
nasty
luke van whaley is black dutch grand
master he's high 2600s 2011 us open
orlando
knight g7
now mark plays bishop g5 making it
difficult for black to
move this knight manueli is heading for
g6 with his knight this is a common
sicilian idea
bishop g5
f6 uh
a serious weakness which mark is induced
and he goes back to e3
and after knight g6
bishop b3 b5 the most famous move of the
game
and this is i think what inspired mark
to write his mayhem in the morrow book
this of course had been his analysis
from many years ago like he knew exactly
what he was doing but vanueli as to my
knowledge was already out of theory now
since that game
there's about 50 games in this position
boom 95.
okay
now you have to accept the sacrifice
because if you decline it then bishop b6
traps the queen
so you kind of have to accept it
but now i play z takes d5
well you're attacking the knight van
wily has to move it
and only after white's next move do you
begin to understand what it is that the
bishop is doing on this diagonal that's
a big hint for you guys
what did white do here what did mark do
not rookie one
d6
locking the bishop on f8 opening up the
diagonal for his own bishop
and paving the way for
a massive attack against the king
bishop b7 when willie develops whatever
he can
knight takes e5
now the point here is that
if f takes e5 um which van whaley played
well if knight takes c5 which when will
he didn't play
to my knowledge
white plays f4 chases the knight away
and then the e file attack is going to
be disgusting and
when will he plays ftxc5 but now mark
opens everything up boom f4
i mean just look at black's king it's
stranded in the center because of this
bishop the bishop on f8 is stuck
and so white has just one tempo with
which
he can open up everything f4 anyway
queen f6
now the e file is open f takes c5 queen
takes c5 now another beautiful move
bishop g5 this is an amazing move it
stops black from castling
but doesn't it blunder the bishop
who knows what mark's idea here is
and this is like amazing amazing
geometry
so not rookie one i know a lot of you
are thinking rookie one it's not rookie
one it's queenie one
well what's the difference the
difference is that after king d the
queen swoops into a5 and it's mate king
c8 queen c7 is mate if you go the other
way then the bishop drops into f7 with
checkmate
and if black tries to give away a piece
white's not just passively taking on e7
white is still gonna go bishop f7
either the king has to walk into a
devastating discovery down the f file
or the king has to go the other way and
we already know the drill queen a5 queen
c7 mate
so after bishop g5 out of desperation
venuli goes bishop e7
now before taking that bishop marco's
bishop f7 check so that
he's able to take this bishop with check
knight takes c7 now he's won the piece
back he makes the comma of queen d2
defending the bishop preparing rookie
one this is as you can already see
totally and absolutely crushing
and just a couple more moves king c8
now mark gets his rooks into the game
rook c1 and rook fd1
queen f5 and now the final idea bishop
drops back to f4
another amazing move preparing queen d6
queen c7 with unstoppable checkmate
takes
windy6 oh mark is in the chat
look at that welcome
and i'm sure i'm butchering half of your
analysis here because i don't have the
engine but
remember this is just to show you the
general arc of what i'm talking about
king d8
i was actually there at the tournament
um
and now who can spot the final
combination
this is really the cherry on top
and you have to be precise in such
positions
rookie one is
probably winning as well yeah rookie one
has to be winning because queen c7 is
threatened
after rook c8 you go the other way
but mark played rook takes c6 just uh
blasting through
oh right after we got back from madosk
where we both played as well takes takes
and black resigned
the point is that the rook is attacked
if the rook goes to c8 you go bishop g5
and black has to give up his well this
is actually just made in two because
queen e7 queen takes d7 as mate
and
that's it if queen takes f4 white
doesn't even take the rooks white just
takes on d7 with mate
and well i resigned here
yeah so if a 2670 goes down like this
then
think about what you can do to 15 1600s
in the mora
so
yeah and i'm happy that mark is in the
chat to appreciate this moment this is
great
um buy his book i'm going to be a
shameless shill
asics uh is what our opponent played now
i'm not familiar with this move i'll be
honest but we decided to play it much
like we would in a standard more bishop
c4
and g6 yeah this is very typical for
players because they play the dragon and
then they think they can do the same
thing in the smith more unfortunately
this is just too slow in most positions
because
essentially in this position black has a
very hard time developing that's the
whole point
the point is that if black goes d6 we
have the c5 idea which by now you guys
are familiar with yeah
stopping knight f6
de5 there's bishop f7 you understand why
this is so difficult for black because
he's just not developing fast enough
and the way our opponent played is a
very classic mistake at this level e6
combining e6 and g6
nine times out of ten
is in such positions as a terrible idea
the swiss cheese defense yeah that d6
square especially if you can get a knife
there which is exactly what we did
is
is unsustainable and there's one very
important exception which i will talk
about very shortly
and
i've shown many many times
my game
against a 1700 when i was 1800
i almost lost a game like this in just
like two moves which i've shown many
times on my stream this game was in the
mora by the way and this is a case in
point i was already 1800 and i didn't
know what to do
that that was the last time i accepted
the smith mora this game even though i
won it which is kind of funny
i was nine nights so i played knight c6
and then i played g6 so this is the
thing yeah i was a night off player but
i figured that here it makes sense to
play bishop g7 bishop c4
bishop g7 castles and now i played e6
which i got a very stern talking to for
my coach
you guys already know the drill what did
dwight do now here i haven't even played
a6 which would have been
a little bit more reasonable if i had
had this move already played
not queen d6 although that happens on
the next move
what did i say what piece should get to
d6 it should be the knight
boom
okay i won knight f6
hoping for the check on d6 and i figured
yeah black is in trouble but it's not
that bad
and out of the blue my opponent goes
queen d6 which i had completely
forgotten about
knight c7 cannot be stopped
and it's either gonna win the queen or
in the event of queen e7 it wins a rook
and leads to a rook trade i managed to
win this game what essentially happened
is that i won this night at some point
and then i had an exchange in two pawns
for the
yeah i had a
piece and two pawns for the rook but
obviously if white plays this well then
he's completely winning
i won the game i ended up tricking him
so
[Music]
the rest of the game is not too
interesting white ultimately failed to
evacuate his knight
and then yeah so i won this knight on a8
and then he blundered again
and
i just won all of his pieces
yeah nine years old
this is may 2005
but i still learned a very important
lesson and those are the best kinds of
lessons you learn them and you still win
the game
pretty lucky
okay so obviously
we can't go knight p5
but we did go e5 and that's just an
alternate pathway for the knight to
approach d6
f6 is the losing move i think black has
to probably go 97 or maybe black should
go f5 here and try to prevent knight e4
although
i mean this just looks so bad bishop g5
and queen d6 is coming
i don't even know what black should do
97 94 castles maybe is the way to
prolong the game but just look at this
position
and we don't even have to rush to get
the knight to d6 that's the important
part is that we're controlling that
square
perhaps in some cases then i could even
go to f6
um
but f6 we just ignore
and then the final cherry on top is b3
b3 preparing bishop a3 and
this is game over
i mean look at look at black's king it's
got no escape and
it feels like we have more pieces than
black does
because black has neglected his
development
and then the only important thing was
knight e4 and then reshuffling our
knights
in order to
get the king
onto this diagonal then we take b7 at
the very least
or we go knight f7 we win the queen
our opponent took and the rest is the
rest is not interesting and once again
we will play more smith warrior games
this is just an
introduction so don't feel like you have
to learn all of the theory right here
and right now
just sort of putting this on your radar
the yeah the reshuffling of the nights
can be hard to see you know these
retreating night moves in general
this is a bit of a weird idea knight e4
knight fg5 and then knight back to these
things but it should make sense to you
and we're just getting the king as far
back as possible
what is the ideal way for black to play
well that's something i'll go over later
and i have to do some research myself as
far as i know one of the sort of
traditional reputable line
is
i mean again this is
why you should get the mayhem the morrow
book but e6
and this line with e6 and a6 like this
has been traditionally considered the
main line i think queen e2 and then rook
d1 and
you know the drill
but i'll do some research we'll talk
more about it we'll talk more about it
and uh thanks guys for for hanging out
this is a fun stream
[Music]